Dozens of agents sprinted across the blacktop.
Weapons drawn, they fired indiscriminately
at the building ahead of them.
They only had a matter of minutes to stop
this mad plan before it was too late.
But navigating the airbase was proving to
be almost impossible.
Banana peels littered the runway, tripping
them over at nearly every step.
Colorful plants were springing up through
the cracks, ensnaring their boots and chomping
at their ankles with rudimentary teeth.
Somewhere high above them, a mutant reptile
was throwing hammers at their head from atop
a cloud of white gas.
The agents struggled and fought their way
to the hangar, but it was too late.
The rumbling of engines, the belch of smoke,
the crashing sound of a hole being blasted
through the roof, they were too late.
Out of the smoking hangar rose an airship.
Painted a sickening red and composed of hunks
of scrap metal, the ship was shaped like a
top hat.
There was a globe on the deck and a sail billowing
out of the top.
The door to the airship crashed open, and
out of it burst a man with a bushy mustache,
denim overalls, and a red hat.
His eyes burned, lit up with the flame of
a man with nothing to lose.
He stared down at the agents below him with
a carnal fury, watching as they were chomped,
crushed, and blown up beneath him.
But then his eyes drifted up higher into the
sky, towards the prize that he was really
after.
The one thing that would bring the love of
his life back to him.
The moon.
The airship puffed out a thick cloud of acrid
smoke and shot off into the air, rising higher
and higher, as the crazed Italian growled
from its deck.
‘Let’s-a go!’
*
New York City.
The city that never sleeps.
Or rather, the city where you can never get
to sleep.
The constant car horns, drunken yells, and
general chaos of Manhattan can really get
to you, especially if you live in a cheap
apartment over a convenience store.
Max had been living here for the better part
of a year now, and the only way he’d found
to unwind on the busy nights was to sit down
in front of the TV and play video games.
Sleep was off the table, so that was the next
best thing.
The pipes under his sink were busted, but
he couldn’t be bothered to call in a plumber,
he had better things to be spending his money
on.
He’d been desperate to buy a Switch for
years, but they just hadn’t dropped in price
in true Nintendo fashion.
He was pretty sure if he fast-forwarded to
the apocalypse, he still wouldn’t be able
to find a Switch for anything less than full
price.
Staying up late checking out Ebay auctions,
he’d unbelievably actually found one.
Some grandma was selling it along with all
her grandson’s other games.
According to the item description, her grandson
had been hospitalized after he broke both
his hands trying to punch a tree.
Apparently, he needed the wood to build some
kind of ‘table’.
Anyway, he’d been banned from playing any
games as a punishment since he’d been getting
too obsessed with them.
So lo and behold, a used Nintendo Switch was
in Max’s hands.
He’d been waiting for years to play Super
Mario Odyssey.
After watching the Mario movie the other day,
he couldn’t be more in the mood to sit down
and play supposedly one of the best games
of all time.
And play it, Max did.
Eyes glued to the screen, he sat there on
his couch all the way through the night.
Mario leaped through the Cap Kingdom with
ease, stomped his dinosaur feet through the
Cascade Kingdom, conquered the Sand Kingdom
while jamming out to the music, and plowed
on.
After fully exploring each Kingdom, he’d
hop onto his hat-shaped airship and fly to
the next one.
All Friday night he played and didn’t even
realize when the sun came up on Saturday morning.
He loved to see all of his favorite characters
on screen, Bowser in his white suit, Cappy
in all of his spinning glory, Peach looking
radiant as usual, and…
Sam.
Max wracked his brains, he was trying to remember
if he’d ever come across this guy Sam in
a Mario game before.
He was just some Koopa, much like any of the
others, except he had a white shell.
Every world that Mario would visit, Sam would
be there somewhere, often hidden under a Sphinx
or behind a waterfall.
It was the same dialogue option each time.
Whenever Mario approached Sam, a speech bubble
would pop up.
‘I want salt and meats.
Bring them to me.
Hurry up.’
But try as he might, Max couldn’t find any
items resembling salt or meats anywhere in
the game.
What would they even look like?
It all seemed very out of place compared to
the moons he was supposed to be collecting.
It was only once Max reached New Donk City
and met Sam standing shiftily in a back alleyway
that the dialogue changed.
‘No salt and meats, huh?
Solve the food shortages.’
Max tried talking to him again, but the game
wouldn’t let him.
No matter what he did, he couldn’t interact
with Sam anymore.
He searched all over New Donk City, looking
for anyone who could point him in the direction
of some salt or meats, but there was nothing.
None of the other characters mentioned anything
about food shortages.
That was enough of that.
Taking his headset off, Max sat back on the
couch and rubbed his eyes.
How long had he been playing for?
Long enough to work up a real appetite.
Planting both hands on his knees, Max pushed
himself to his feet and wandered over to the
fridge.
There wasn’t much in there.
A bowl of leftovers, some cheese, a few options
but nothing like what he was really craving.
He pushed his way through the back, and his
eyes lit up.
There, behind everything else was a little
box he’d forgotten to throw out the previous
week.
Mushrooms.
Would they still be good to eat?
He didn’t care.
Taking gone-off mushrooms by the handful,
he shoveled them into his hungry mouth.
That’s how he’d grow big and strong.
With a satisfied smile, he slammed the fridge
door closed and stared at himself in the mirror.
He must have been gaming for a long time.
A thick tuft of hair had appeared on his upper
lip.
Looking this way and that, Max admired the
mustache in the morning light, muttering under
his breath.
‘Mama Mia.’
*
SCP-3843 is a little-known bug that appears
in physical video games.
Much like a biological virus, it is transmitted
from one copy of a game to another through
close proximity.
If one game in a collection exhibits evidence
of SCP-3843’s presence, it likely means
that all other games in the owner's collection
also have become ‘infected’.
But what is SCP-3843?
Well, that much is currently unclear.
The game’s coding appears to undergo no
changes when affected, and yet a new non-player
character appears when the game is booted
up.
How this character manifests depends on the
video game itself, but there are a number
of consistent rules.
Firstly, the character always fits within
the world of the video game with a small identifying
feature.
A white-shelled Koopa in Mario, an extra crew
member on the Normandy in Mass Effect 2, and
even a diamond-shaped block in Tetris with
a hole cut out of the middle.
Secondly, this NPC is always identified as
‘Sam’ or some variation of that name if
it is necessary to change it to fit into the
world.
For example in Elden Ring, SCP-3843 takes
on the name ‘Sam of the Starving Plains’
or in Pacman it becomes ‘Sammy’.
One elusive characteristic of these NPC characters
are their obsession with salt and meats.
In the majority of incarnations, any which
allow the character to have dialogue, Sam
always expresses a desire to be given salt
and meats with follow-up dialogue usually
complaining of food shortages.
On occasion, the game will contain additional
food items that seem to be generated by SCP-3843.
For example, when Sam appears as a merchant
in Nier Automata, it will sell you cubes of
a non-descript salty meat.
If the player chooses to consume those items,
nothing appears to happen.
Tracking down instances of SCP-3843 has become
easier in recent years.
The decline of physical game sales with the
shift to a more digital ecosystem has meant
that transmission between copies has reduced
significantly.
A physical disc or cartridge is required for
transmission, after all.
What is more, Foundation testing has revealed
that his SCP is incapable of infecting online-only
games.
Multiplayer shooters and MOBAs are totally
immune to it.
In fact, any game that requires an internet
connection to play will be immune to transmission.
While gamers do hate the trend of having to
be online to play their single-player games,
there is a big upside to it from the Foundation’s
perspective.
Who knows, perhaps there are agents placed
in certain publishing studios pulling some
strings to help crack down on SCP-3843 transmission…
It wouldn’t be the first time the Foundation
has meddled with the gaming industry to try
to control the outbreak.
Little-known developer Indigo Games launched
in 1980 to relatively small fanfare.
They flew under the radar over the three years
of their existence, closing up shop in 1983.
But their effect on the games industry was
enormous as they are believed to have been
the source of the original instance of SCP-3843.
With the sale of physical games blowing up
in the early 80s it was the prime circumstances
for Sam to spread like wildfire.
Without much other choice, the Foundation
had to step in.
Due to a large number of SCP-3843-1 instances
becoming public in 1983, the Foundation resorted
to emergency containment measures.
To achieve this, they caused a crash in the
video game market by using their resources
to influence major players.
This involved financing competing home computer
companies, artificially saturating the market
using Foundation-owned companies and undercover
elements in existing companies, using Foundation
elements to encourage poor business practices
in existing game publishers, and sabotaging
upcoming projects.
It was a success.
The gaming industry slumped, and sales fell
through the floor, buying enough time for
the Foundation to get on top of instances
of SCP-3843.
You must be wondering by now, what’s so
bad about Sam?
Just a harmless NPC popping up in video games
asking for salt and meats.
Where is the harm in that?
You would be right.
In the context of the game, no real damage
was being done.
The issue came from the real-world repercussions
of encountering Sam.
You see, when someone chooses to interact
with shopkeeper Sam, start questgiver Sam’s
storyline, or engage mini-boss Sam in combat,
it marks the beginning of a physiological
change in the player.
What this looks like depends on the game.
For Zelda Breath of the Wild, it’s just
a case of the person growing blonde hair,
a higher-pitched voice, and developing a sudden
affinity for swordsmanship, puzzle solving,
and hang gliding.
The player undergoes physical change to make
them more closely fit into the world of the
game they are playing while also gaining knowledge
and skills akin to what their player character
would possess.
The first instance of this posing a real-world
threat was when Daryl MacKenzie, 24, was shot
dead whilst infiltrating a US military base
after playing an infected copy of Metal Gear
Solid.
Before his death, he had exhibited high-level
espionage and combat proficiency, which his
family all claim he had no knowledge of prior
to this event.
Other cases can be even more severe, such
as when the player character is not just a
regular human.
Infected copies of Cyberpunk 2077 and Deus
Ex Mankind Divided result in players growing
electronic implants in their own bodies, which
most often leads to death as their immune
system rejects the technology.
Instances where the players control non-human
creatures are even more severe.
One woman sprouted cat ears and thick fur
all over her body before suffering multiple
organ failure.
An agent checking her PC found she had over
1000 hours logged as a Khajit character in
Skyrim.
Often the Foundation is only a couple of steps
behind infected game copies, and so is able
to step in and help those affected.
This, unfortunately was not the case with
Max.
Three weeks passed, and Max felt like he was
on top of the world.
He’d fixed the problem under his sink no
problem after finding he suddenly had a wealth
of plumbing knowledge somewhere in his brain.
He’d gone through his entire wardrobe and
thrown out all of the awful clothes he used
to wear, replacing them with much better outfits.
Red caps, denim overalls, big brown shoes.
It was the perfect look for him.
Every morning he would sit in front of his
mirror and sculpt his mustache to perfection,
carefully trimming the hairs to the exact
right shape.
Exploring New Donk City was his favorite pass
time.
He’d kick open the door to his apartment
and stroll out onto the street, looking for
adventures every day.
Jumping on the roofs of taxis, playing jump
rope in the park with children, exploring
the sewers looking for adventures, swinging
around the flagpole on the Empire State building,
he was having a fantastic time, despite all
the looks he was getting from passersby.
But one thing played on his mind the whole
time.
Peach.
She was still under Bowser’s control.
It wasn’t fair of him to have all this fun
while the love of his life was a prisoner.
He needed to collect enough moons, that’s
what mattered.
But no matter where he looked in New Donk
City, he just couldn’t find any.
The only moon he could see was the one sitting
there in the night sky.
Staring out of his apartment window, Mario
- Max - hatched a plan.
His apartment was slowly coming to life around
him.
Little piranha plants grew out of pots on
his window sill.
He’d bought a gun a few days ago, and already
the bullets had grown little faces and arms.
He was assembling a small arsenal here.
Enough to take the moon by force.
*
He heard the pounding footsteps before the
door to the hangar flew open.
An agent stood there holding a gun in trembling
fingers staring into the darkness.
Max let the smile slowly creep across his
face as his gloved hand hovered over the launch
controls.
The agent called out into the shadows.
‘Who’s there?’
‘It’s-a ma…’
Max cranked the lever forward, and his airship
kicked into the sky.
‘Mario!’
Gunfire rang out from all directions as the
ship rose into the air.
He cackled maniacally on the deck, watching
the agents getting torn apart by all of his
traps.
They weren’t going to get in the way of
him reaching his Princess Peach.
Not today!
On the ground, the agents stared up as the
hat ship flew away from them, higher and higher
into the sky.
Only the faint echo of a ‘Wahoo!’
drifted down to their ears, before Max ran
out of oxygen and passed out on the deck of
his ship.
Now check out “SCP-049 Fights...SCP-343
is the Referee - Dr Bright Starts a Fight
Club!” and “SCP-1471 MalO, but HACKED
MINECRAFT”!